[Musique]
après un séjour à paris thomas s'apprête
à revenir à montréal au comptoir on lui
refuse l'embarquement en raison de
surréservation l'agent lui réserve une
place sur le vol suivant quatre heures
plus tard et lui offre un coupon repas
mais l'agent denis a pas tout dit thomas
peut réclamer beaucoup plus huppés du
règlement de l'union européenne prévoit
un dédommagement selon longueur du
trajet et du temps d'attentes et un
retard de quatre heures lui donne droit
à 600 euros environ 835 dollars waouh
mais attention ce règlement ne
s'applique pas en cas de force majeure
et il s'applique seulement si je
voyageais transporteurs de l'union
européenne ou si vous décoller d'un
aéroport de l'union européenne comme de
man a décollé de paris il a droit aux
dédommagements
même si vous voyagez avec un
transporteur canadien le fin mot de
l'histoire
l'union européenne vous protège mais ne
comptez pas sur les compagnies aériennes
pour le dire